a warning from one of the UK's largest
companies that Britain risked
squandering its leading Green Technology
I think the risk is
um over time we will lose another
leading cutting-edge industry where the
UK could be a global champion
retailers hoping for a coronation we can
boost as consumer spending remains
subdued in April
JD Sports to pay more than 520 million
euros for one of the biggest sportswear
retailers in France
plus course for companies to cut down on
the Alcohol served at work parties to
improve staff Behavior
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City one of the UK's
largest companies is one in the country
risks losing its leading Green
Technology because of a lack of support
from the government the chief executive
of Johnson Matthey which has a 40 share
of the Global Marketing catalytic
converters says his company could help
UK become a leader in green hydrogen but
instead may lose out to the U.S which is
providing hundreds of billions of
dollars in subsidies for firms making
similar products or join him in our
economics editor Ed Conway
thank you I mean this is fast becoming
one of the biggest issues facing the
economy right now the question of just
how different countries around the world
are going to make this transition to Net
Zero and also equally importantly what
happens to their economies as a result
you're going from a situation where you
have lots of internal combustion engine
car factories you're going to a world
where you may need lots more in the way
of battery factories hydrogen factories
and so on and so forth and where the UK
stands in this no one quite knows at the
moment except to say that we are
starting to lag behind many of the other
countries and one of the key things here
is that in America they have something
called the inflation reduction act many
hundreds of billions of dollars being
passed towards those green companies uh
in the UK so far we don't know what the
strategy is going to be we're having to
wait for the government to come up with
it and a lot of people are worried about
that and among those companies that are
very worried about it is Johnson Matthey
they produce well they are one of the
world leaders when it comes to platinum
Metals which you use in all sorts of
different chemical uh chemical
applications and one of those is green
hydrogen anyway this is our report from
Johnson Matthey
any hope of eliminating greenhouse gas
emissions then we will need what they
make in this plant just outside Swindon
for this is where Johnson Matthey makes
the chemicals and membranes you need for
green hydrogen a fuel produced without
carbon emissions the UK doesn't make
many batteries or solar panels but this
is one area where we're genuinely
competitive but the boss here says
that's no longer a given well I think
the risk is
um over time we will lose another
leading cutting-edge industry where the
UK could be a global Champion so I think
batteries is gone we we've lost that we
don't move with that sense of urgency we
will lose that next
um a round of innovation as well that's
real jobs for the future
um future-proof jobs for the next
decades so I think this could have a big
impact it's like many other firms is
looking at subsidies being thrown at
Green Technology firms in America by the
White House's inflation reduction act
and asking what about the UK the lack of
of certainty and Clarity is a problem
today and practically again a lot of
jobs are getting created in the U.S
right now those some of those jobs could
be created in the UK but because of lack
of clarity and certainty they're not
getting taken now
um so it's already it's already costing
potential jobs for sure for sure many in
business are now wondering whether this
might in hindsight turn out to be the
moment the UK dropped out of the race to
build the green technologies of the
future this is one of those rare areas
where the UK is actually a world leader
when it comes to the chemicals that are
pasted on what are going to be kind of
membranes going inside fuel cells in the
future the issue is so much of this
technology so much green technology has
been drawn away to America where all the
subsidies are and the UK is now faced
with an awkward question what's it going
to do to try and encourage businesses
like this to invest share in future
so what to do about it the problem is
even if it wanted to Britain can't
compete with the hundreds of billions of
dollars being thrown around elsewhere we
need to really choose where the money
can make a difference because otherwise
you either subsidize something that was
happening anyway or you subsidize
something where we're not very good at
it and we then find ourselves pouring
more and more money into it so we need
to be yeah it's hard work it's not a
casual business
the green Industrial Revolution is fast
turning into a race but for the time
being it's not clear whether the UK is
competing and how much help its firms
will get to do so
well Ed I mean the thing with Johnson
Matthey is it had a very very promising
electric battery materials business
which a lot of faith was put into and it
pulled the plug on that last year has
been thrashing around for an identity
ever since isn't this just special
pleading by this company I think I mean
that's that is a really interesting
point here because you know they were
like you say they were putting many
hundreds of millions potentially in
something called cathode active
materials it's the special chemicals
that get pasted onto electrodes that go
into the batteries and then I think it
was just last year they basically canned
that and said they weren't going to go
down that road and part of the reason
for that and I think this is kind of
instructive is that they felt having
kind of dipped their toes into that
water that it was already too late that
China had basically sewn up that market
for batteries and their strategy instead
was going to focus on hydrogen there's
lots of question marks over whether
hydrogen is going to be quite as big of
a deal when it comes to this as a lot of
people think it's going to be certainly
there's a lot of hype about it but even
so even even those who are skeptical say
this will play a part in the energy
transition you can need hydrogen say for
the storage that you have the energy
storage when you're kind of generating
lots of energy from wind turbines you
need somewhere to store that energy for
days when it's not when actually all
that windy and hydrogen is part of the
answer for that so there is kind of a
big part that it will play and
interestingly the UK does actually have
a lead here we do actually have a
strategic Advantage for the time being
why because some of that expertise that
JM have when it comes to catalytic
converters they can then use when it
comes to these uh these hydrogen kind of
electrodes in a slightly better slightly
more applicable actually for them than
the Battery Technology but to get to
your kind of broader question yes a lot
of companies around the the UK in
particular are screaming at the
government for assistance here and yes I
mean of course it's because they would
quite like some free money they'd like
some subsidies who wouldn't
but the difficult issue here and I don't
think there is a straightforward answer
to this is that you now have for the
first time you know since the 1970s
America throwing extraordinary amounts
of subsidies you know across this
different parts of this sector that
Europe is doing much the same thing as
well China obviously is doing the same
thing as well and the UK is kind of on
its own and it's not clear whether we
are standing out and taking this kind of
firm line and saying no we don't really
want to be a kind of you know picking
winners economy or not and given that
all of that it's no kind of surprise
that lots of Manufacturers and make UK
the manufacturing group was just saying
this uh just over the weekend that they
need some kind of strategy there is no
strategy at the moment there is no
clarity as to what the UK's response to
all of this is going to be maybe it's
going to be subsidies maybe it's going
to be just saying okay we're going to
take the upper hand we're going to take
the the high road but we don't know at
the moment and we're not going to know
till Autumn and right now companies are
making decisions as to where they put
their money where they put their
investment and right now a lot of that
is going into America
okay thanks for that and we will of
course be speaking to make UK later on
in the program
now retailers and the hospitality sector
will have been hoping the coronation
weekend will have given a boost to
consumer spending for evidence today
from barclaycards suggests spending was
pretty subdued during April Rising just
4.3 year on year which was less than
half the headline rate of inflation that
though represented an improvement on
March when consumers spending as
measured by the company Rose by just
four percent on a year-on-year basis
will joining me now is the Barclays
director Esme Howard Esme welcome to
spending on clothing and restaurants
down for three months running now I mean
that's the Bedrock of consumer spending
isn't it
look at lots of different categories and
I think there are some bright spots as
well as areas where perhaps retailers
will be struggling if we look at an
example of a bright spot one would
really be entertainment actually Spen
growth there was up 12 year on year and
what we think is driving that is
spending on tickets for example
Eurovision and also people being out and
about with their families over the
Easter holidays yeah I think the pub
trade did quite well didn't it over
Easter correct so pubs were up and 3.7
so that's real positive news for them
and also we've seen um Sports and
Outdoor retailers going back to growth
or after a more negative period for them
and I think as we look towards the
summer people will start booking their
holidays we're already seeing that
Airline spend is up 32 so as I say
definitely some bright spots on Horizon
what about grocery spending though that
was a bit of a laguard as well grocery
spending was up 5.5 year on year in
April and of course you have to put that
into the context of food inflation which
was over 19 so what what we think is
happening there is that consumers are
making a real effort to cut back on
essential spending wherever they can to
offset those Rises and prices and
they're doing that in lots of
interesting ways 67 of us making a real
effort to try and reduce the cost of the
weekly shop looking out for those yellow
stickers exactly yellow stickers a third
of people who are trying to save money
are deliberately choosing those items
around the same proportion they're
looking to use loyalty points or
vouchers that they've accumulated and
two-thirds of people are actually doing
what we call swaps so choosing own brand
items for example
um or perhaps swapping out fresh for
Frozen one of the things that struck me
is Pharmacy Health and Beauty did rather
well what was going on there I think
often you find as the weather gets a
little bit brighter people try to
brighten themselves as well and I think
it's interesting though that that spend
had increased while clothing spend
actually decreased and you also found
that spending on houses by which we mean
things like Furniture DIY electronics
that also took a bit of a tumble so it
feels like that's perhaps a little bit
of an outlier what about the coronation
weekend is it too early to sort of uh
draw any conclusions there it is too
early to say with um any definity but
what I would say is that typically on
National events or occasions we often
see a bump all right Esme got to leave
it there good to see you this morning
thank you thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and JD Sports is paying 520 million
euros to buy one of the biggest
sportswear retailers in France Korea
which is currently owned by the private
Equity Firm equestone Partners Europe
owns 313 Outlets across six countries in
Europe with France Spain and Belgium its
biggest markets it further has franchise
Arrangements across some 36 outlets in
North Africa the Middle East and French
overseas territories or Regis Schultz
who's JD's chief executive said career
was held in high regard and the European
sportswear community
the average highest price fell last
month according to figures published
this morning by Halifax the UK's biggest
mortgage lender said house prices fell
by 0.3 during April and month-on-month
basis which it said was the first such
decline this year on a year-on-year
basis house Prices rose on average by
0.1 percent down from an annual growth
rate of 1.6 in March Halifax said this
represented the slowest year on year
increase since December 2012. on a
regional basis the southeast of England
performed worst with a year-on-year fall
of 0.6 while the strongest performer was
the West Midlands where Prices rose at
an annual rate of 3.1 percent
the ftse 100 company DCC announced this
morning that Donald Murphy is chief
executive will step back from his
day-to-day responsibilities for the next
few weeks the sales marketing and
Support Services Group which specializes
in energy Healthcare and Technology said
Mr Murphy's absence was to address a
medical condition well Mr Murphy has
been with the company for 25 years and
chief executive for the last six years
having previously headed its energy
Division and taken it from a small UK
and Irish business to an international
business operating in 12 countries
the hybrid estate agency purplebricks
said this morning it was not now
expecting to return to generating cash
during the next few months purplebricks
had previously said had expected to
return to cash generation early in its
Current financial year which began at
the start of this month but it said
today that instructions during the three
months to the end of April had not
increased at the expected level well the
company which put itself up for sale in
March said it had engaged with a
significant number of potential buyers
but the likely return to shareholders
was likely to be materially below the
closing price last Friday the shares are
currently off some 54 so far this
morning
now the chief executive of Royal Mail
Simon Thompson is an advanced talks to
leave the company it sought that
International distribution services
which is Royal mails London listed under
could announce as soon as this week that
he will be stepping down well joining me
now is Guy City editor Mark Lyman who
broke this story Mark what's the latest
well the latest is Ian that we're
expecting a statement from International
distribution services at some point this
week Mr Thompson is in discussions with
the board about the terms of his uh
departure and I don't think anyone will
be too surprised at the news that Simon
Thompson is to step down as the chief
executive of Royal Mail after all you
would struggle in to find a chief
executive of a London listed company at
the moment who's had a more toroid
tenure over the last couple of years
than him obviously Royal Mail has been
hit by a wave of industrial action it
has however recently agreed a deal with
the CWU the main Union representing
Royal Mail staff that will see them
being paid an extra 10 percent uh over
the next three years as well as a 500
pounds lump sum and the ballot of CWU
members opens in the next couple of
weeks just a day before IDs
International distribution services
announces its four-year results so
there's some curiosity about the timing
of this expected announcement from from
Royal Mail as I say the details yet to
be finalized but I would expect an
announcement from uh IDs in the next
couple of days that Simon Thompson is
stepping down as the boss of Royal Mail
Mark what about these calls for a d
merger uh of IDs by shareholders are you
still picking up much on that front
yeah I mean they've been Gathering
momentum over the last few months in of
course before the deal with the CWU was
announced there was intense speculation
that the board of the company Was
preparing to take the very drastic step
of potentially putting raw males letters
and Parcels business into Administration
the pay deal that's been reached with
unions should avert the prospect of such
a dramatic measure having to be taken
but at the same time there is clear
investor dissatisfaction IDs about the
uh fact that the loss making Royal Mail
business continues to be part of this
broader group and at some point I
suspect that pressure will become
intolerable for the uh for the IDS board
and there will be some sort of corporate
corporate separation of the Royal Mail
business announced uh certainly in the
next couple of years I would expect
all right Mark thanks for that
now it's nearly six years since the
former business secretary Greg Clarke
unveiled his industrial strategy he was
promptly torn up by Boris Johnson's
government and since then the business
department itself has been revamped is
to that backdrop that a surveyed by May
qk the body that represents UK
manufacturers has just found the
majority of companies believe there's
never been a robust government vision
for manufacturing it's now calling for
the establishment of a royal commission
as a first starting point in the
development of a long-term modern
industrial strategy who are joining me
now is Seamus Nevin he's make UK's Chief
Economist Seamus welcome to you what a
royal commission achieve hi and yeah
well as you said make UK is calling for
a royal Commission because so many
manufacturers say that we have never
really had a long-term industrial
strategy every major industrial economy
in the world from Germany to China right
now has an industrial strategy and as
was mentioned earlier on your program
the United States under the inflation
reduction Act of the Biden
Administration has committed 400 billion
dollars to uh its industrial strategy
the EU is doing something similar so the
absence of an industrial strategy in the
UK is really leaving us behind and 80 of
manufacturers in the UK say it puts them
at a competitive disadvantage so what we
want to see is a royal commission that
hopefully can reach a broad cross-party
consensus about what a long-term vision
for UK manufacturing will be so that we
can set clear directions for investment
strategy going forward well you've just
talked about the subsidies being
showered on businesses by the US and the
EU I mean industrial strategy presumably
is going to be more than just chucking
subsidies out absolutely and this isn't
just a case of businesses coming cap in
hand to government and asking for money
it's really more about setting a
direction of travel so when you look at
the investment cycle of a typical UK
manufacturer it's about seven years
between the process of inception when
they first start exploring a potential
investment and the full implementation
of that investment yet as we've seen in
recent years many government schemes
though often well-intentioned and well
designed they typically last for less
than two years so they're not lasting
long enough for businesses to see the
full benefit of that so really what we
want is commitment from from government
that that we have determined something
that is strategically important and that
is worthwhile pursuing I mean under
Boris Johnson the government did
announce a ten point plan for green
Industrial Revolution I mean did that in
order to match an industrial strategy of
a Kind well if you look at the last 15
years as an example when it comes to
Industrial strategy we've had 15
different Ministers of secretaries of
State responsible for the various policy
areas that would be included in an
industrial strategy we've had seven
different policies that could be
described as an industrial strategy and
the primary Department responsible for
industrial strategy the business
department has been restructured five
times and that's without getting into
the game of tennis that has constantly
being played between education and
business as to whether
um apprenticeships and skills policy as
an example is a responsibility of the
education department or the business
department so what we really need is
consistency and once something is
decided to actually stick to it and see
it through to fruition because that's
where I think the real benefit can be
gained can all that be blamed laid at
the government store I mean part of that
feels like it's just Whitehall turf wars
some of it is and and this isn't about a
party political point or even a a
government point it's about setting the
institutions in place that's why we've
asked for a royal commission for a broad
consensus so that regardless of who is
in power we still have a consistency of
vision and also we've we've called for
the re-establishment of the industrial
strategy Council as an oversight body to
monitor that policy to to see what can
be learned from lessons previous and to
feed that institutional knowledge back
into policy making in future so that we
we know what's right and what works and
what doesn't
what about Greg Clarke's industrial
strategy I mean did that actually have
any good ideas in it or was it just not
given enough time by Johnson absolutely
I mean when you look at the history of
industrial strategy in recent times
we've done a lot of really good things
whether it be the Super deduction
um of the the previous uh uh budget or
um the sector deals uh brought into
under Greg Clark the real problem is not
that we haven't done good things because
often we have it's just that we don't
stick to them when we do we want to see
those those commitments uh maintained so
that businesses can can read the real
rewards yeah you walk to creation of an
industrial strategy Council what sort of
people would be on that well the idea
would be that it would be our relevant
stakeholders so business groups uh major
manufacturers government ministers think
tanks perhaps anybody with relevant
expertise the point is to ensure that we
have as much knowledge and information
as possible to make the best decisions
in the Strategic interests of the
country and I think the other aspect of
this is it's not just about a business
is in the short term when it comes to
the UK and its longer term Vision it was
absolutely right for the government to
focus on securing trade continuity
agreements with many of our
International Partners after we left the
European Union a couple of years ago
what we want to see now is that a focus
not just on the quantity of agreements
but the quality of agreements and doing
that will
will require a clear knowledge and
understanding of what it is that we're
asking as our strategic objectives and
what are our defensive objectives so
what are we looking to gain and what are
we willing to sacrifice in exchange for
those and part of that will be hugely
important to understanding where the
Investments should be made and
underpinning any industrial decision
making thank you James good to see you
this morning thank you
still to come here only in King live
we'll have a look at how Global markets
are doing this Tuesday morning stay
tuned
[Music]
foreign
they have breached the road there is a
lot of protesting fired all around us
[Music]
it is
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news the roads have been
inundated the only way out is to get
people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted I'm Neville Lazarus
and I'm Skye's reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
well last night's mixed trade on Wall
Street during which the NASDAQ entered
bull market territory was followed by
mixed trade overnight in the Asia
Pacific region Nikka in Tokyo gained
more than one percent to finish closer
to its best level since January last
year that was on the back of some decent
company results it was all fairly soggy
elsewhere and Europe's markets have been
in negative territory so far this
morning as you can see all the main
Continental European indices in the red
right now talking points today include
Daimler truck it's off Sun three and a
half percent in Frankfurt that's after
it left its year and forecasts unchanged
well here in London the ftse 100 is also
a negative territory off a third of one
percent right now there are some gainers
to mention though in the education firm
Pearson is the leading one of them in
the uh index it's ahead by some three
percent that's following the
presentation in which it outlined how
it's making use of generative AI
investors being very anxious on there
what that might mean for Pearson in the
last couple of weeks or so on the
downside the student housing group unite
Group shares off there nearly two and
three quarter percent that is on adverse
broker comment outside the ftse 100 was
a real Trio of mid caps in the wars this
morning the building products group
Marshals is off some 10 and a half
percent right now following a profits
warning while the insurer direct line is
some six percent lower that's on a
downbeat trading update meanwhile the
bottom of the screen there victrix the
polymers group their shares off ten and
a quarter percent that's after its
results came in below expectations not a
lot of cheer in the mid 250 this morning
as for the currencies well Sterling on
Monday hit its highest level against the
US dollar since April last year it's
given up a little bit of those gains
this morning actually it's more or less
unchanged right now against the
Greenback the pound also up a fifth of
one percent right now against the Euro
that's for single currencies of a
quarter one percent against the dollar
as for the oil price well that rallied
sharply on Friday ahead of some strong
U.S jobs data and it's Consolidated
those gains yesterday but not today it's
giving back some of those gains Ballard
Brent crude will currently set you back
76.36
sense about that is off four fifths of
one percent will joining me this morning
is Guy Foster he's Chief strategist at
RBC Brewing dolphin guy good to see you
this morning while the UK was getting
itself excited about the coronation on
Friday afternoon there were some very
very strong U.S jobs numbers morning Ian
thanks uh thanks for having me on yes so
that was uh that was Friday we did have
these uh jobs numbers these uh the most
exciting moment of any month for anyone
in investment strategy even though the
numbers tend to be revised and such like
they are a really good gauge for the
factors that drive consumer spending in
the US and that makes up the majority of
GDP and is very globally influential as
well so as you say the numbers actually
were quite strong I think we probably
shouldn't get too
um excited by that they've they tended
to be a bit better than expected
um month after month after month but
there's a few metrics that that are key
here so how many new new jobs were
created so that was that was strong
figure that obviously the more people in
work the more able they are to spend
uh also how much are they getting paid
so actually wages were a little bit
stronger uh than had been expected in
fact a slight acceleration in wage
growth and that's something which I
think people have been expecting uh to
drift downwards and then another key
metric is the unemployment rate so this
is essentially uh how many people could
be drawn uh into into into jobs and that
actually edged slightly lower now over
the last year that would have been bad
news
um because people have been much more
focused on inflation than on economic
growth and so it was interesting to see
how the market greeted these numbers as
being quite good news which just shows
how people are more concerned now going
forwards about a recession than they are
about a resumption in the kind of price
increases we've been seeing over the
last year or so absolutely would that
explain why the the dollar has been
somewhat uh I mean you would expect the
dollar to rally on these numbers and
it's not really done so not a huge
amount no and I think they um I mean a
lot of that what's going on there is the
difference between what's going on in
Europe what's going on in the UK and
what's going on in the us when we talk
about one currency we can only really
measure it in terms of other currencies
so we've had similar sorts of data
elsewhere and there's kind of global
Trend I know you've been talking about
consumer spending a lot already this
morning and it has been very interesting
to note consumers are generally holding
up okay what you're seeing is the mix of
their spending uh shifting
particularly away from Goods to towards
more services particularly away from the
kinds of things well showing a bit more
pressure I think for lower income
earners maybe than higher income earners
who are proving quite resilient in this
environment now we get uh interest rate
decision from the bank of England last
week we've got Rises last week from the
ECB and the FED do you expect the bank
of England to follow suit this week I do
expect that yes absolutely but I think
the focus is not so much on what happens
this uh this meeting it's it's what
happens in future meetings because the
UK as we all know has higher inflation
than other regions a lot of that has to
do with the particular nuances of how
our utilities bills work here and so I
think we will see that in a couple of
weeks time we will see actually UK
inflation at last start to come down a
bit more meaningfully than we've seen so
far but ultimately with employment still
quite strong even though you're starting
to see a bit of moderation in spending
it's very difficult for the bank of
England not to keep raising interest
rates guy could live with them I'm
afraid good to see you this morning
thank you
still to come here on air King live
calls from the chartered Management
Institute for companies to cut back on
the Alcohol served at work parties I'll
be speaking next to its CEO
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back now the Scandal at the CBI
has put Behavior art work under the
spotlight and caused many companies to
look at whether they are doing enough to
prevent inappropriate behavior well to
that backdrop the chartered Management
Institute has called on companies to cut
down on the amount of alcohol available
at work functions joining me now is Anne
Frank she's the chief executive of the
CM I am welcome to you you're not
calling for booze to be done away with
all together I hope
no Ian we're not but it's interesting we
did survey over a thousand managers at
CMI and what they told us is is
enlightening uh actually uh 42 percent
of them said they felt that uh work
social dues should not be organized
around alcohol that doesn't mean you
can't serve it but it should not be the
main event they'd prefer other
activities and let's face it uh there
are many other activities that companies
can select and that view was
particularly held by young people where
almost one in two felt that way and by
women
is this a bit of a generational thing
then
partly I think it is Ian as we know the
younger Generations tend to drink less
alcohol but also partly it's in response
to what people have seen so what we also
found in cmi's research was that
um really almost one in three people had
witnessed inappropriate behavior at work
social dues involving alcohol that's not
to say that people don't want these
social events they do and three quarters
are very comfortable attending them and
think they're very important for morale
it's just that we do need to avoid the
kind of inappropriate behavior that
happens when you drink too much
doesn't it risk making workplace
functions a bit joyless if you're sort
of restricting the number of servings
that people can have of a glass of wine
for example
many people think uh actually I'm
absolutely fine with um limiting the
number of drinks to a reasonable number
you know a couple of drinks or actually
I'd prefer to socialize with my
colleagues doing other activities
whether that's crafting or sporting or
um you know discovering some new
interest together so I think that the
sort of fallback notion that a work do
is a boozy do is becoming somewhat
outdated in today's modern workplace
and what we've got you this is the first
chance we've had to speak since the
whole CBI Scandal what's your assessment
of how the organization has handled this
well Ian I don't want to get drawn in to
come commenting on individuals but what
I would say is I think this is a wake-up
call that you you can never as a senior
leader you should never prioritize
competence over behavior and as a senior
leader it's incumbent upon you to create
the culture and to ensure that that
culture
um is actually uh delivered in line with
your values throughout your organization
and I think that is the lesson for all
of us here
um and you know I think leaders and
managers need to be much more
professional in how they look at the
behavior within their own workplaces I
mean the new director General Ray
newton-smith and her predecessor Tony
Danko were both seemingly unaware of the
fact that there were a few bad apples in
in their Workforce I mean isn't that a
problem for managers I mean there are if
there if there are Bad actors in a
company it's very very difficult for
even the best management to weed them
out
well at CMI we do believe that
professional management and Leadership
also encompasses being curious about
your own culture and ensuring that you
have the processes and mechanisms in
place whether that's management by
walking around or encouraging people to
speak up or proper reporting mechanisms
to deal with those few bad apples we all
know that many of us in our workplaces
will have bad apples it's really how how
you deal with them how swiftly you deal
with them that matters because we know
that you know you can't prevent them all
together and that's part of professional
management and Leadership
good to catch up with you this morning
thank you thank you
that was just over four years since HMV
closed its famous store on London's
Oxford Street a site opened by the
composer sir Edward Elgar in 1921. more
recently one of many less salubrious U.S
Style candy stores has occupied the site
but now HMV which currently has 120
stores across the UK has signed a lease
to reopen on the site later this year
and it's promising to revive the
in-store appearances and performances
made famous by the likes of take that
blur and the Spice Girls I've been
speaking with hmv's owner Doug Putnam
it's a long-term lease we've got some
options on it as well so you know we're
going to be here for uh quite some time
which is great to see
remind me why HMV vacated the site in
Oxford Street to begin with
yeah at the time the the rates were
exceptionally High the rent was
exceptionally high that the store was
losing millions and millions of pounds
um and so we just couldn't make a deal
work uh as soon as the the bankruptcy
happened
um and then since then we've been trying
to get back in and see if we could find
a deal and obviously in covid and uh it
now feels kind of like the timing is is
right
um you know landlord is willing to work
with us on it and the government's
helped a little bit with uh with some
rates help uh for retailers in London so
I a few things have added up to make it
work out well for us
how long are you going to have to take
to refit the store and make it fit for
purpose
yeah I mean obviously there is a candy
store in it and I think it was like
making for a long time many years I
walked by that store and I'd see the
sign but uh nothing in it so you know
what we're hoping to be open before
Christmas
um that's really the the target so it's
going to take many months to get it back
up to where we need it to be to get open
now obviously that store was very famous
for in-store performances by the likes
of blur and I think Amy Winehouse
performed there as well it's not going
to be a big part of the reopening have
you got a big act in mind to to support
you in that
yeah I think we're talking to a lot of
different bands and uh I think our
Outlook is that we're going to get a lot
of great bands to come here I mean it's
a great location part of London so I
think yeah we're going to see a lot of
Great Performances happen uh over the
coming years and certainly on opening um
we've got a lot of big plans
a lot of people are very skeptical when
you bought HMV that you'd be able to
compete with online retailers but I mean
you've still got 120 stores up and down
the country clearly you've been able to
do so what would you say has has helped
you in that
um part of it is that we've kind of
looked at what our customer wanted and
yes they want CD and DVD but obviously
they want it vinyl and they want pop
culture and you know apparel and fan
t-shirts so I think really listening to
to the customer I think uh our team's
done a great job of that and then
putting in products that that resonate
with the customer and if you look at our
demographic now when I first bought it
it was a lot of middle-aged and older
and now when you go into the store and
on a Saturday it's amazing how many 8 9
10 13 year olds are in the store
um so I think that's kind of really
helped us a lot is just broadening our
age demographic
What proportion of sales these days are
what you might call Purely music as
opposed to other aspects of pop culture
your business is getting pretty close to
split evenly you know you've got CD and
and uh doing well uh DVD 4K kind of
slowing a little bit final continues to
to grow so I think our mix is getting
pretty close to even between all the the
formats and then pop culture being there
as well so I think that's kind of helped
where if we could you know if as you
know uh DVD slowed pop culture is picked
up vinyls picked up to make up for the
loss and we're actually seeing growth
which is great as a chain
I gather you've actually seen an
increase in CD sales over the last 12
months
yeah it's unbelievable I don't think we
ever would have thought uh we'd be
saying yeah CD is on on the rise which
is you know who would have guessed it
but definitely CDs have have grown for
us uh first time I think they told me in
20 years so and what do you think's
behind that
you know I just think more and more
we're getting people that want to
collect
um you know whether it's vinyl or CD and
so they want to buy special editions or
something new that's coming out so I
just think we're seeing that a fan is
willing to buy a lot more than they used
to be they want all the different colors
of vinyl they want the CD they want the
T-shirt so I think you're getting more
spend out of the customer who loves
their their band
and obviously the BPI the industry body
uh pointed out recently that cassettes
are back in Vogue as well will he be
stocking many cassettes in this store
well look when they do the new releases
and we have because that's we do we buy
some used cassettes look it's on the
rise but it's still very very small but
I just think it's it's pretty cool to be
able to talk about it actually you know
people wanting to buy it so I don't
think we think this is going to be the
next final or anything but uh we'll
we'll carry it just because it's pretty
neat I was laughing though there's
customers who come into our store they
don't even know what it is you know if
you think about it if you were born in
the last how many years you walk in
you're like what what is this that don't
even know what a cassette is so I think
that part of it's kind of nice as well
when you see a customer who has no clue
what a cassette even is that is great
and what about uh Continental Europe
I've got plans to open some Outlets
there as well
we do we're gonna get going on that
um you know fill our managing director
has been really good at pushing things
over the line you know he's helped
greatly on this Oxford Street but yeah
he's got a lot of plans for for Europe
which is great so I think uh I think
we're all pretty excited to see if this
concept Works uh Beyond uh the UK
that was Doug Putman from the HMV now
the latest figures for the trade deficit
recently highlighted the difficulty the
UK has in generating a sustained rise in
exports but one industry which is
enjoying a trade surplus is advertising
and Market Research Services or figures
published by the advertising Association
the industry body revealed that the UK
exported 15 billion pounds in
advertising and Market Research Services
in 2021 that compared with Imports worth
just under 12 billion pounds I've been
speaking with Julian dunk Douglas he's
the international chief executive and
vice chairman of vccp the advertising
agency that bought us compare the
markets meerkats and the current Saga
holidays campaign featuring the actor
Nicholas Farrell
we have the most advanced digital
marketing country on the planet and so
International companies all around the
world want to buy the best and the UK
really is the best our creative
Industries have always been fantastic
whether that's music fashion and
architecture design and advertising is a
real crown jewel amongst those
Industries
there was a big rise in uh advertising
Imports seven billion to 12 billion you
worried about that no not at all because
with 15 billion exports we've still got
a significant Surplus and it's really
important that we do have those Imports
so make sure we're we're learning from
other nations from other other areas of
development and Tech so so we really
stay at the Leading Edge and do we have
lots to learn from other countries in
this discipline of course I think there
has to be a symbiotic relationship you
know that we're a world leading uh
nation in terms of advertising and
especially technology but we we also
need to work with new areas without
India be that West Coast in the US
apart from the US and Australia most big
consumers of uh British advertising and
marketing services are in the EU has
brexit had any any impact at all on on
the way that you do business well we're
still seeing significant
um trade and exports going out to
Germany especially in Ireland and so
that continues to be the case I guess
the bit that's an area for concern is
Talent so the reason that UK does so
well at advertising is education
training and talent it's about the
people and we've got great people right
across the country but we also have the
best people in the world coming to work
in our country and so there could be
some challenges of being able to access
the talent from across Europe and has
that actually manifested itself at all
well it's still too early to say so so
we're continuing to see how that plays
out now the UK has just joined the cptpp
the trans-pacific trade agreement is
that going to benefit the industry over
the course of time I certainly hope so
you know removing barriers to trade is
is only good for business
um and that the true scaling
opportunities I guess it remains to be
seen but we're hopeful and what about
the media landscape more broadly right
now I mean it seems as if consumer
spending is under pressure companies
probably looking at their advertising
and marketing budgets what are you
seeing on the ground right now well I
think there's always pressure on
marketing budgets um but equally every
every company that wants to grow
advertising Market is absolutely key to
drive that growth and I guess the more
they're accurate accuracy we haven't
been able to understand the effect of
advertising the more investment we can
put that one thing that really strikes
me has been quite interesting at the
moment is that online advertising
appears to be reverting to the way that
traditional advertising channels are
operating now for example BuzzFeed have
just closed their news Operation because
their advertising is drying up is online
advertising now becoming like say TV and
display advertising I think it's
constantly evolving it's very Dynamic
space with lots of change as this new
technology becomes available there's new
platforms there's New Media channels so
it's it's always changing three in every
four pound spend it in UK advertising
spent or digital formats in some regard
so I think it's it's I think it's ever
changing and what about the streaming
platforms obviously there's a lot of
debate about them right now how
effective is is advertising on a
streaming platform I think it's it's
absolutely key because I think
advertising it's not just about your 30
second spot yeah advertising comes in
many shapes and forms and through
different channels through different
sponsorship deals through through
placement in in programming so I think a
lot of the activity is very much uh
fueled to advertise them now your
company gave the world uh the meerkats
from compare the market of course they
were pulled off screen off to the
Russian invasion of Ukraine they're back
now were they ever in danger of being
permanently pulled well the meerkats
have been Best Loved icons for about 15
years now
um and I think it's fair to say that the
UK population loves the meerkats and
they've been very effective for compare
the market but I think the UK public
also gets that they're fictional
characters and they're not real and so
as a responsible Advertiser compared to
the market are always reviewing uh the
impact and the sentiment around their
advertising and and in doing that so
it's all no reason not to continue with
with Alexander and and these Pals
an old meerkat fans will be delighted at
that news I'm sure well still to come
here on Ian King life why bubble tea is
turning into one of taiwan's biggest
exports don't go away
foreign
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of protesting fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute Carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
body types of Victory
these students have to find a privately
orders and now they're going to be
arrested we aim to be the best and most
trusted place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted I'm Neville Lazarus
and I'm Skys reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
news to bring you we don't have much
details on this but uh we understand
that the former Pakistani prime minister
Imran Khan has been detained uh
following a court appearance on
anti-corruption charges uh he is said to
be in custody that's all we have at the
moment we'll bring you more news as we
get that throughout the morning here on
Sky News
now if like me you have teenage children
you probably know all about bubble tea
the Taiwanese sweet beverage that's
become hugely popular around the world
one of the biggest players is gongja
founded in Taiwan in 1996 it's got more
than 2 000 sites in 22 countries
worldwide or currently 10 of these are
in the UK but the company is planning a
major expansion I've been speaking with
Paul rainish he's the global chief
executive of gongcha and asked him if he
thought the UK Market could take 500 new
stores
we've had probably slow slot in the UK
um but we just opened in Brighton last
week and and had an incredible number of
customers all through the weekend uh
doing over 400 cups a day which is for
us uh fantastic
um and so with that kind of demand I
think you know 500 stores is a good
number there's no reason why we can't
get there certainly with the gong cha
model
and uh would this stools be would these
all be franchised or would some of them
be company owned or how would it break
down
you know we have different kinds of
models around the world but I think UK
is is right for franchising uh you know
it's a really popular vehicle for for
investment and
um you're working with some great
Partners to to roll out the brand and
what would you look for in a franchise
partner
really starts with quality of operations
you know we really care a lot about the
quality of our tea uh and the and the
great sense of service that we have
around the world and so in the UK you
know a franchisee that had really
demonstrates fantastic customer service
and and makes the product consistent all
the time to uphold our quality uh and
value is is really Paramount so you know
someone experience great operations
um they can be well capitalized too but
you know even these days with uh with
tough interest Market uh capital is
readily available and in terms of when
you would be looking to partner with a
franchisee how many outlets would you
typically want them to take on
yeah um we're working through that now I
mean we do have a partner already who's
got 13 Stores
um and they're going to grow with us but
there's more opportunity right
throughout the country uh including uh
you know Scotland and Wales and Ireland
now who's the typical what does a
typical customer look like is it I
presume they're quite Young on the whole
you tend to be you know it's it's um
really fascinating when the brand
started in Taiwan in 2006 uh Small
Beginnings but it really has taken off
with almost 2 000 stores around the
world now
um in 22 countries and so you know a lot
of people think that maybe bubble tea is
tend to be sort of an Asian consumer but
we're really finding a broad a broad uh
cross-section of of people uh enjoying
the product every day
um what we're moving towards is this
daily ritual uh you know coffee seems to
have done that and we're breaking
through with tea what do you think's
behind the success of this uh phenomenon
bubble tea
are these uh you know quality flavor
variety value
um sort of the core tenets of of a great
you know Beverage Company at gongchang
we try and lead on all of those and uh
that's how we find a success I think
it's partnership too partnership with
great franchisees around the world and
the passion that all of our team have
for making great beverages every day
um you know gongsha is an incredible
business uh that is really skyrocketing
now last year we opened 245 net use
stores grew by 25 in revenue and created
over 2 000 jobs so we're really proud of
that and we'll keep that momentum in the
future years and who do you regard as
your primary competition is is it
independent bubble tea Outlets or is it
the likes of Costa and Starbucks
well I think it's any beverage occasion
um you know we're trying to break
through you create this daily tea ritual
uh in the UK it's great for their army
that's uh what everyone everyone does
but you know the coffee business is very
saturated and I think people certainly
are looking for a change and a variety
uh every day so why not get gongcha
you've worked for a number of uh players
in the uh fmcg space the likes of Subway
Dunkin Donuts to name a few I mean What
attracted you to this business
really is the opportunity for scale I
and I don't think many brands have gone
from the East to the west and here's
gong cha I think it's a chance to do
that and prove that you can actually you
know create demand build big business
um and you know invest Capital uh with
the technically Asian contract concept
um but do it for a greater broader
appeal globally
um and our model really works for that
so you know franchisees are profitable a
customer demand is certainly
strengthening uh and people love the
quality and variety of our beverage
um particularly the fact you can
customize you know you can make over 600
combinations and throughout our menu uh
whether it's you know the inclusions you
have or the tea varieties
um and I think it's the quality of the
tea is sort of at the core of everything
we do you've opened up recently in
Belgium and Portugal as well which are
the other new markets that you're
targeting
yeah we're gonna have a busy year
um I'm here in Dubai actually uh we're
going to have some exciting news in the
next couple of months but you know we'll
open in the Middle East this year uh we
have France opening just before the
summer uh the Netherlands again before
the summer and uh you know will probably
into Thailand uh by Q3 Q4 so you know
again good expansion quality candidates
and we'll be aggressively developing
now a bit more breaking news for you
concerning Imran Khan the former
Pakistani prime minister Reuters is
reporting he has indeed been arrested
outside the Islamabad High Court where
it says continue to paramilitary forces
and armored personnel characters entered
after him and blocked the gates more on
that story throughout the new morning
here on Sky News do stay tuned up next
it is Jane second I'm back with you at
10 o'clock tomorrow hope to see you then
thanks for joining me today